enchant me simplify my life make me
amazing they're incredibly one-sided
wedding vows and the three key
principles underlying the Android teams
creative vision for the platform and the
apps that run on it as engineers it can
sometimes be difficult to see past our
own delight at harnessing the power of
an SDK to bend a machine to our will but
ultimately our goal must be to create
that same empowering experience for our
users and we do that by creating apps
that are aesthetically pleasing as they
are functional and easy to use users
judge the quality of your app within the
first 30 seconds it may not be fair but
a disproportionate amount of that
judgment will be based not on the
functionality but on the visual
aesthetics does it look polished does it
look professional how easy is it to use
more than just looking pretty the entire
user experience is critically important
with 30 seconds to win users over it's
critical that that onboarding process
that time and effort required to go from
downloading your app to performing its
main function should be as short and
frictionless as possible not only that
but a well-designed app should evoke a
visceral reaction that speaks to the
subconscious it should be fun to use it
should surprise in delightful ways
through subtle animations and smooth
transitions that contribute to a feeling
of power and effortlessness it should
let users touch and interact with
objects directly rather than having to
use buttons and menus and it should use
rich imagery and pictures in place of
lots of words and long sentences it
allows users to customize your app to
make it theirs while providing beautiful
and sensible defaults create something
that works like magic learning your
preferences in the context provided by
the device so it never asks users for
information that they've already
provided provide simple shortcuts to
complete complex tasks and remember data
settings and customizations making them
available across every device while it's
good practice to create a familiar and
welcoming experience by creating a look
and feel that's consistent with the
platform's styles and themes it's just
as important to remember that this and
all the other principles I've discussed
here are really just a starting point
for your own creative vision
deviation from the guidelines is
encouraged but when you do do so deviate
with purpose